they've conquered bakeries and sweet
desserts worldwide but the original
Portuguese custard tart the pastel de
nada was created in Lisbon nearly two
centuries ago just one Bakery claims
ownership of that first very secret
recipe and Remy inocencia went to
Portugal to visit the famed pastesh de
bella
a shower of sugar and cinnamon spice
mmm then that crunch of a Portuguese egg
tart
oh my Lord
so nice it triggers all your senses not
only taste it can also smell it you can
see it you can hear it as well 40 year
old Miguel clarina runs the perpetually
busy paste to Belen
a pleasure having these rooms filled
with noise and laughter that's why we're
here Portugal's original egg tart
business has been here for nearly 200
years now popping out 25 000 Tarts each
day says clarinya and for countless
customers Millions yeah for sure it's
been in his family most of that time
different faces across five generations
but the same kitchen to this very day
this is like pastry heaven for me
feeling Goosebumps on the back of my
neck uh to be right in front of these
freshly baked you'll have one just uh
they're too warm you need to wait a few
minutes just one I'm gonna have more
than one sure
but no luck on knowing the recipe well I
can't show you inside but I can show you
the door uh in the office
or Workshop of secrets so the four chefs
make the pastry and the Custard in this
room so only four people in the world
know the recipe and the three owners and
the retired Chef so eight eight inches
yeah
so what's the secret
it's not only the ingredients but it's
mostly the way you mix them in the art
and heart involved the first part of the
process we are allowed to see is the
prep of the puff pastry the experience
of years
to measure as women press and round
techniques passed down through time
next door the egg custard yolki yellow
is whipped up thick like pudding
perfect proportions piped out
then it's into specially made industrial
ovens that sear them at an incredible
750 degrees Fahrenheit to caramelize
their tops Scorch splotches the
Portuguese style once cool they're
brought out to customers craving a bite
of History
we don't know exactly the year it was
invented but uh we believe it was in the
beginning of the 19th century or in late
18th century
invented by monks yes not men of the
Hearth but men of the cloth as The Story
Goes monks inside the 14th century
geronimo's Monastery just a few minutes
walk away used egg whites to starch
their clothes with all those leftover
egg yolks the recipe for the very famous
and very yellow
pastestinata was born
Within These Walls among the tombs of
Portugal's most famous explorers the
recipes stayed secret for perhaps a
hundred years until the monks starved
for cash after the Portuguese revolution
of 1820 sold their recipe to a
businessman across the street that's
where it began in 1837 there was just
the front counter a few cakes a lot has
changed obviously ever since the only
thing that remained exactly the same is
the the recipe and and the way they're
made how many have you eaten in your
lifetime I probably had about a thousand
of these in my lifetime that's pretty
and I don't really like sweets so wait
you don't like sweets except here we are
yes it's one of those live sirenis right
the pleasure of the Portuguese egg tart
a National Treasure turned International
treat a Savory sweet once tried you
can't help but repeat for CBS Saturday
morning raymie inocencio Lisbon Portugal